the Greeks and Romans gave us so much
that it's little wonder we continue to
sing their praises as great inventors
artists and writers but not everything
they thought has stood the test of time
here are five of their most absurd
pieces of wisdom number one if a woman
says no she means yes of it a highly
damaging piece of advice from the Latin
poet Ovid sky to love women act coy he
maintained and may even put up a fight
but secretly they want to be overcome in
battle now two women today especially in
the era of me - it's pretty apparent and
in fact the poem from which this piece
of advice comes actually helped land of
it an exile for being so sexually
explicit to dark-skinned men produce
black seamen Herodotus
herodotus the so-called father of
history believe this to be true both of
ethiopian x' and certain indians to
modernize it may look racist but to him
it was a little more than a curiosity
worthy of note he did not provide a
source of this nugget
apparently believing it to be true
simply on logical grounds perhaps he
thought it was one of those well I never
anecdotes that would enliven his
histories of Greece's wars against
Persia three women are incomplete men
Aristotle
together with Plato Aristotle was the
most influential philosopher from
antiquity he wrote on everything from
drama to animals but he did entertain
some rather peculiar ideas about biology
he saw men and women as completely
different men were hot and dry women
were cold and wet every production
happens properly he thought then the
embryo should be male like its father a
daughter as the result of a man's semen
being too weak to overpower a woman's
reproductive matter for women who seemed
monkeys during intercourse their
children who resemble monkeys sir honest
a medical marvel from Sir honest a
doctor of the Roman Empire his thinking
is that you can inherit not just the
physical characteristics of your parents
but even the thoughts they had when they
were actually conceiving you sir honest
thought it particularly important that a
woman be sober during sex
just in case she conceived a deranged
child he also advised her against
picturing monkeys or other animals in
case the child came out looking like one
far better to picture a statue so that
the child might have long graceful limbs
but hopefully not be too rigid and cold
five
beware the fifth day of the month it is
dreadful Hesiod in the seventh century
BC a poet called Hesiod composed a poem
on the farmers year he believed that
some days of the month were more
suitable for some tasks than others and
endeavoured to give landowners the best
possible advice fifth days struck him as
picky Lily threatening Hesiod misgivings
haven't stood the test of time
but perhaps in the future people will
look back on us and laugh for us finding
Friday the 13th so unlucky thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon